california's wildfire danger is still
high this morning but officials say
better weather is helping firefighters
seven people have now died fire damage
has gone from 56
000 acres at this time last year to 1.4
million acres
now jonathan bigliotti is tracking
efforts to control all the damage
fourteen thousand firefighters are
racing to keep some of the largest
wildfires california has ever seen
from getting any bigger we are
essentially living
in a mega fire era
we have folks that have been working for
cal fire
for the last five years and that's all
they've understand is
mega fires the fires massive enough to
see from space
are now about the size of the grand
canyon
they've been burning for more than a
week we didn't have time to do anything
just get dressed get out there
ken and marcy albers returned to the
town of vacaville monday
to find a pile of ash and debris where
their three-story home once stood
their neighbor died in the fires by the
time i saw the fire his place was
already
burned down further south in santa cruz
mark kutzler
battled flames with the help of a
friend's old fire truck
this whole side was engulfed in fire
racing towards the house here
he saved nearly a dozen homes in his
neighborhood
i feel proud of myself i feel that i'm
really happy that some people get to go
home to your house
so far there have been more than 600
fires across the state and the governor
says there could be more so-called
sleeper fires like this one undiscovered
because of the steep terrain and the
dense smoke
firefighters say it could take several
more weeks to extinguish all of the
flames
long battle jonathan thank you